took on Russia within a few months he
paid the price his coalition government
brought down in a vote of confidence and
petkov says Russian influence here goes
hand in hand with corruption I can make
it I can tell you Russia would have zero
influence in this country if Bulgarian
politicians are not corrupt the
instrument of influence in this country
is through corruption and what I'm
trying to say to all the international
viewers and the Bulgarian voters is that
our fight against corruption is the same
fight against foreign influence
when he was prime minister petkov
refused to pay for Russian gas in Rubles
the supply line carrying 85 percent of
the country's energy needs was cut off
petkov set about finding alternative gas
supplies and opening up a pipeline
between Greece and Bulgaria was a start
but it couldn't stop attacks from the
likes of boyco borisov a former prime
minister who has an 11-year leadership
record he lost power after
anti-corruption protests but opinion
polls claim he's the election favorite
with this vote the people will tell us
who should retire who should leave or if
we should be United or they'll say you
can't do it without each other
borisov is Accused by peskov as
squandering three billion dollars of
taxpayers money it was on a gas pipe
project he says that connected Serbia
and Hungary with Russia but gave no
access to Bulgaria and bypassed Ukraine
people just don't know who to trust in
this election many politicians are
hiding their Russian sympathies and on
top of all of this the Kremlin is
mounting its biggest disinformation
campaign here ever
people aren't just confused they're
disillusioned the ability of the voters
to actually make an informed choice
between the two camps has been
significantly hindered by the huge
degree of disinformation those
politicians in sections of a society who
are critical of Moscow are adopted as
traitors
faith in Bulgarian democracy is as
fragmented as its political system
there's a strong likelihood that this
election will be inconclusive and that
would suit the Kremlin Andrew Simmons Al
Jazeera Sophia